hello everyone
uh hope you enjoyed the series that was
quite a wild ride for me
and if you didn't watch i highly
recommend it it's this amazing story
about a family that left war in the east
of ukraine and is starting over
the reason for this video is because i
want to get money together
to get running water
in the family's home
i saw
firsthand
what a pain in the butt it is to live
without running water in the home so i
want to get a bathroom
and a kitchen
so this is where the burku family needs
our help
and i've started a generosity campaign
where you can donate
a very small amount
or a large amount or whatever you want
and
what is cool about it is i'm going
back to osupenko i'm currently in lake
tahoe california nevada usa
but i'll be going back
and making a video
of actually installing
a kitchen
and a bathroom
this family
is beautiful as you can see in the
videos and
if we could help them
save what probably two hours a day by
dealing with getting water from the well
if we could get it in their home
we
together
can make their lives much much much
better
so
there will be a link somewhere in this
video
or you're on the generosity website
already but you can click on it
and donate if you're interested and if
you're not interested
that's fine and
i really appreciate you going along
on this journey with me it's been
well a life shaping experience for sure
okay
thanks again
any questions you might have leave them
in the comments below
and i will come back to you in not too
much time
with a video
getting water
in the home and they will be so thankful
to you all
to be continued
[Music]